david leader of the lib dems is
with us so boris johnson has gone it's
what you wanted um but you know he was
always the full guy for you guys so who
are you going to punt who's going to be
a punchbag now actually it was the whole
conservative party uh when we were
beating them the three by-elections the
last 12 months in their heartland in
trouble blocking buckinghamshire in
north shropshire their seat that held
for 200 years and then overturning their
massive majority in devon when we spoke
to lifelong conservatives yes some of
them
were angry with boris johnson that was
the reason they switched i won't deny
that
but far more we just fed up the
conservatives
partly for propping up johnson for so
long but also a feeling that they've
been taken for granted
that the conservatives were all voting
for these huge tax risers uh and they've
broken the election promises so for for
us actually it doesn't really matter who
the candidate is because they're from
the conservative party
i i i think voters will be switching
still to the liberal democrats so what
happened yesterday because um labour was
trying to get boris johnson out of
number 10 altogether i'm guessing you
would have supported them in that but it
didn't happen
yeah i mean a bit of wrangling i think
between the labour and government whips
officers
liberal democrats have been calling for
a vote of no confidence in the prime
minister for a long long time and
although he has sort of gone he's still
there
and the thing about this particular
prime minister who i really don't think
is a decent
prime minister at all
he's unpredictable
i don't think he can be trusted
and he still has some power even these
last few
weeks and days
he can for example appoint people to the
house of lords when he retires and i
don't think we want
boris's mates who've been responsible
for this total disaster we've seen under
boris johnson certis you know going to
the house of lords i think it'll be
wrong you've got a question today
well i'm hoping the speaker will uh pick
me uh and i certainly have got a
question but i'm actually not going to
tell you what it is i want to surprise
the prime minister oh so you've been
working on it in front of the mirror
have you
not quite like that just having a chat
my mind going around as i
brush my teeth you know okay uh rishi
sunak um
looks so is the front runner
worried
no not at all i mean let's face it he's
the architect of all the tax risers
i mean not only did he get a fine along
with boris johnson for breaking the
rules uh in knockdown he's actually been
the architect of 15 tax rises
so a lot of the unhappiness that we
picked up from lifelong conservatives
who are saying look we've got these
energy bills we've got these food prices
going up we can't afford to fill up our
car
all these real issues that
conservative voters and frankly
everybody is worried about rishi sunek
has not really provided the help that
people need and you know there are
millions of families and pensioners out
there desperate for some help and rishi
sunak has been the person who could have
provided it and he's failed time and
time again you say that but you know it
is up to the grassroots conservative
party members who
of the final two becomes the next prime
minister if they choose rishi sunak it
means that he was doing the right thing
well i don't think the uh with due
respect to conservative party members
the nestle representative of the rest of
the population and some of them may well
be able to afford the higher bills but
my concessions many of my constitutions
can't and i suspect huge numbers of your
viewers
won't be able to afford the energy bills
that are going to go up uh very very
steeply i mean i spoken to people not
just in these by-elections not just
locations but just you know in my
surgery and so on
um and people are looking to christmas
with a degree of anxiety i've never seen
before
i think there is the reality is i think
people get it
um that we could be in the worst cost
living emergency for decades and people
who are already struggling are going to
just not
don't know where to go
and the government hasn't done anything
and and so
given those
really difficult decisions people are
having to make
um
the failure of sunac and the failure of
all these story candidates to actually
stand up for for ordinary people who do
the right thing who play by the rules
who go to work who look after their kids
they just want a fair deal okay and this
government is not providing that deal
i'm doing a double shift today and uh
covering prime minister's questions so
we'll keep an eye on whether you get
your question or not and how you deliver
it we'll give you mark's out of 10.
thank you thank you thanks